hey what's going on it's bill burns it's
time for the thursday up sorry it's time
for the monday morning podcast for
monday
march 2nd
20222
march matching like a lamb out like a
lion
or whatever the hell they say how's it
going
how's it going with you guys i hope you
guys had a great weekend
i hope you caught that celtics brooklyn
nets game i [ __ ] missed it
you know
sitting here trying to fight off a cold
i'm in the middle of a uh
shooting a movie here this whole month
so i got to stay healthy so i just been
laying in bed
you know
i love when you almost catch a cold and
everybody hits you with all their
remedies dude this is what you do you
take a lamb shank right you strip all
the [ __ ] meat off of it
you [ __ ] suck on the bone you gotta
but you gotta get the marrow right
everybody has this thing and then you
still end up getting a cold anyway
i feel like i'm sort of holding this one
off
um i think the biggest thing is as you
feel it coming on you just do a shot of
nyquil
and you go to bed
and you get eight full hours and then
you just slam waters and you just hope
for the best like that's the best you
can do
and but you got to get the real [ __ ] you
got to get the nyquil you can't get that
bootleg [ __ ] that they sell
cvs's
cvs presents our version of nyquil
um
i know there's a bunch of people being
like uh it's actually the exact same
recipe no it isn't
no it isn't
why would nyquil give cvs their [ __ ]
recipe
that would make nyquil null and void you
don't do that
did somebody works at cvs
used to bang you know went out
deliberately went out the daughters with
the person that created nyquil
and after they banged she fell asleep
and then he snuck around the mansion
and [ __ ] got the nyquil recipe and
brought it back to cvs and they're like
great you don't have to [ __ ] that nyquil
chick anymore
and here's your golden parachute is that
what you're telling me what happened i
mean it's the same color
dude nyquil is the johnny walker blue
of just drugging yourself
and going to sleep i'm not getting that
cvs [ __ ] what am i a [ __ ] homeless
guy trying to get drunk
i want the
[Laughter]
i know you're not supposed to laugh
about [ __ ] like that but i mean that is
just a [ __ ] level that you hit with
with like
what would you call that
alcoholism yeah that's the word
addiction
that you're now homeless
and you're not only are you going to get
shit-faced
on cold medication you can try to catch
a buzz on cold medication you have to do
it off of bootleg
cold medication you know
you go in there like well i'm not buying
nyquil what is it my birthday
what is it the [ __ ] holidays let's
let's relax here
you know
this is just a regular tuesday we're
drinking the [ __ ] cvs [ __ ]
hey a buzz is a buzz
that'd be a great scene in a movie huh
two homeless guys
talking about which which boot like
nyquil they'd like to get drunk off of
more the cvs or the rite aid
you know i like to write it you know it
has less of a bite i feel the next day
you know
i feel like if somebody tries to crush
my [ __ ] cardboard box at night i'm
i'm more awake
you know to fight him off
um
anyway
i don't know what i'm talking about here
people um
i guess the celtics had an unbelievable
game with the brooklyn nets i missed
that jason tatum had 54
points
um
kicking it out to jaylen brown for the
[ __ ]
nail in the coffin whatever they call it
the dagger
uh i love watching the celtics man
they're a very entertaining team to
watch and i was enjoying it i was
looking at the highlights and some
[ __ ] [ __ ] still had to write
uh neither one of these teams are making
it to the finals lol
you know that's and i don't know why
that's just one of those things that can
just ruin my day
because i just want to find that person
and being like buddy are you even going
to have a ticket to the nba finals
like who [ __ ] said either one of
these teams were going to make it they
played a great game this guy scored a
bunch of points what the [ __ ] is your
problem
but every once in a while
like you just see is there anything
better than seeing justice and you had
nothing to do with it
so you get to enjoy it without the
ramifications
of being the person that took the
vengeance
to really do the right thing to slap
somebody or something like that you know
i was watching this old episode of uh
foghorn
leghorn
right and it was the episode it's really
actually a really good episode
it's the one where
um
there's the dog
and uh there's this [ __ ] weasel
that's trying to eat the baby chicks and
it's funny is they make the weasel
literally look like a [ __ ] dope
addict
things eyes are all bugged out and
[ __ ] crazy i mean it looks it was
like they were showing you like
what a meth head look like
years before meth well i can't say years
before meth because now they're saying
that the germans were on that [ __ ] i
don't know
and all of a sudden it's like everybody
in the german army was on meth everybody
really everybody was on [ __ ] meth and
now that story's just coming out
new evidence shows that's one of my
favorite things new evidence shows that
christopher columbus actually was afraid
of the ocean and it's like where did
well where the [ __ ] was that laying
around was that just written down on a
piece of paper and somebody finally
decided to pick it up and read it
or
is it suppressed information
because that's something else that i'm
finding out you know as i get older that
you know
what do they say that history was
written by the people by the victors
and uh
you know what victoria's people should
do then is prevent the people that lost
from writing books
because then their version
becomes
like
the version
and what it should be is the combination
of both
it's like if you hear
a rams fan tell you the version of the
super bowl
is
that it was a great rams victory and
they got [ __ ] over on that face mask
call
and if you listen to the bengals fans
their version of it was that the bengals
got [ __ ] over at the end of the game
on a [ __ ] makeup call
so
i don't want to make light
of actual [ __ ] that matters but i mean
isn't that sort of the same thing too
i'll tell you what's really interesting
to me oh when we get back to the foghorn
leghorn thing right so the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] [ __ ] what i love about
falcone leghorn is he's an [ __ ]
but he's not like daffy duck but daffy
duck is just a [ __ ]
idiot right i used to like bugs bunny
but he's also a [ __ ]
you know he picks on a lot of people for
no [ __ ] reason
except for that opera singer you know
opera singer came up [ __ ] him with his
house didn't respect his house
what have some and he throws the [ __ ]
pie in his face
um
yeah so of course bugs has to go out
ruin his concert i understand that but
like a lot of that elmer fudge [ __ ] he's
just [ __ ] with the guy but i guess
elmer one of them elmer fudd is just
going out to get he's looking for gold
he comes in like i've been working on
the wherewit
right he's just trying to [ __ ] get a
plot
bugs bunny sees him and he's [ __ ]
bored he starts [ __ ] with him i
understand later they made him like a
hunter maybe that was like a note
they're like you know i kind of feel bad
for the hunter you know he's just like
i mean for the guy he's just trying to
dig for some gold
um
yes guys this is how [ __ ] this is
where i am with my life right now
so anyway i'm watching but i like
foghorn leghorn because he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but he gets his a lot
you know i don't know that bugs bunny
ever really loses except for that time
he's in the plane with that [ __ ]
mouse
and then the mouse is [ __ ] with him
the whole episode
um
the foghorn leghorn is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and but he gets his ass kicked a lot
right so anyway he uh the dog is
stressing out because this [ __ ]
dope fiend weasel is trying to eat the
chicks
so far going leghorn he's [ __ ] bored
so he keeps letting the chicks out
he's like boy i say boy one just got out
right
and it was really i don't know why i was
watching
episode that cartoon and it was really
given me a lot of anxiety
even though i know if i really thought
about it that we weren't going to show
the weasel killing one of those chicks
right but it was just bugging me
and i was working up this nice sort of
you know
simmering anger towards
far corn leghorn
and
then out of nowhere like i realized that
him being an [ __ ]
was just this giant setup
for this great moment
where at one point he takes this knot of
wood he takes the knot out of the wood
and
he lets the chicks out that way right
and the dog has to run around
and [ __ ] fight off the goddamn dope
fiend
and he gets the chicks back in the
[ __ ] the yard
and he's finally dealt with that
and i'm thinking this [ __ ] rooster's
an [ __ ] right and all of a sudden
falcon lighthorn gets out of the the pen
and he's like hey boy i say hey boy what
am i doing outside
i should be on the inside right
and the dog's just like all right no
problem and he picks him up like he's
going to throw him over the fence
and he throws them through the knot of
wood
it's the hole in the thing that's super
small
and he only gets about [ __ ] you know
his head and his shoulders through it
and the dog picks up a pole out of
nowhere and just [ __ ] jams him the
rest of the way through when he loses
all of his feathers
and i'm not gonna lie to you i [ __ ]
laughed my ass off i laughed so hard
my daughter started laughing from the
other room and ran in to see what i was
laughing about
and um
she came in and i go look at this look
at this and she started cracking up too
and i have to be honest with you i am a
huge fan of joke writers and everything
like that but there's just nothing
funnier than slapstick
there's just nothing funnier than seeing
somebody fall down a flight of stairs
or just you know watching that thing get
shoved through that hole and he loses
loses all his feathers
uh and he gets through the other side
he's like uh someone i say someone close
the door there's a draft in here
it's so dumb but what i really loved
that was so satisfying was he was just
such a [ __ ]
to the dog
and the dog throws him through that hole
and just jams him through it with a
[ __ ] pole
and i don't know what happened the rest
of the episode it just made me thinking
like i just wish that happened more in
life
to people that really deserved it
you know
whatever whatever the human version of
that is they could just every once in a
while you know because now
you know there's just cameras everywhere
and there's just so many people
that really need
a slap
and you can't do it because you're gonna
get on video and then the person that
deserves a slap
is gonna [ __ ] you know
end up winning even though you slapped
them
you know they're going to get a you know
a couple of grand off you because of
emotional distress that it caused them
that you [ __ ] slapped them so
i don't know i really i really [ __ ] i
can't even i can't even believe like how
much i enjoyed that part of that cartoon
and how and it stayed with me like i saw
it a couple days i saw last night
jesus christ the night quit it was a
couple of days ago
um
so
anyway i was uh
i play this new game with mike with my
daughter right
i go into her i go into a room and i
just start asking her like these
questions and she loves you know kids
love talking about you know
what they're into so i just play this
game it's a great way to spend time with
the right
hang out i just go all right
i go let's play
what's your favorite breakfast
of all time
and she's just like okay cool i go all
right
i go do you like do you like pancakes
and she's like pancakes my favorite
thing in the whole entire world so we go
through all of that [ __ ] then we did
lunch so i think i told you guys the
other day i did this so now i went in
there and it's like
what's your favorite thing
in the garage
to ride on
i go do you like your bike she goes i
love my bike my bike's the favorite
thing in the world
and i go do you like your skateboard she
goes i love my skateboard but you can't
go really fast on it unless you're a big
kid
[Laughter]
and
then it gets her asking me questions she
goes you know
she goes i don't like when you go go to
work dad when you go on the road
she goes when you when you go to the
hotels
she goes do you smoke cigars when you're
at the hotel i'm like well i can't smoke
in the room she goes good i don't want
you smoking cigars
at the hotel and i was like all right
and she goes um
do you watch daddy tv which is basically
anything that's not like on the kids
channel like
sports and [ __ ]
i'm like yeah i do
and i was telling her how i was making a
movie
and she goes doesn't have the bad bad
words in it
and i said yes
she goes uh
she goes i want you to do
basically told me she wanted me to do
something
that didn't have bad words in it
so she could see what my work looked
like
which works on two levels
you know like what does the comedy club
look like and uh
and actually the work your act
or the movie that you're in or whatever
so
i told her i would write her a kid's
book
um
i actually had a couple ideas when i got
and that and i was actually thinking
like oh my god this is the moment
this is that moment because i always saw
like comics
you know
who did movies or performance did movies
of certain you know ratings radar and
[ __ ] and then they have kids and then
they want to
they want to do [ __ ]
that their kids can then go see
and and that is the moment
when they stop being funny
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know
that be what are you gonna if your dad's
in metallica are you gonna sit there and
be like dad can you write us can you
write me like a kids song that doesn't
scare me it's like yeah i'll do it for
you but i'm not putting it out
just christ you like working in this
house you live in this house i gotta
[ __ ] i gotta say the bad words
it's what i do
jesus christ if i start working clean
then that's an away game for me
all right i like the friendly confines
of the f-bomb
um
anyway
i saw another funny thing uh
on instagram
the lead singer at danzig was saying
that you know if punk music started now
it would never even get off the ground
because of woken cancelled culture
right and then all these young people
like all right grandpa
you know all this [ __ ] just trashing the
guy
[Laughter]
and then be like oh have you ever heard
of this band oh so there you go right
and uh i just got a kick out of all of
it
because
you know i am
i am an old guy
and then also i love when young people
trash old people
i just always cracks me up and then i
also like that young people like me
think that one day when you get to be my
age or the guy in danzig's age that
you're not going to be saying the same
[ __ ]
because what's funny
is i remember dana carvey on snl
when he was on snl in like the 80s
and 90s you know it was his generation
that was influencing comedy
he had a uh this character of this old
man
saying all this stuff hey when i was a
kid we only had one game it was called
stare at the sun and we liked it you
know
he was making fun of old people
talking about how difficult their lives
were and how everything that young
people were doing wasn't [ __ ] anymore
right and now i'm looking at this danzig
guy
who i think is a generation or whatever
age sort of between my age and dana
carvey's age and now we're so old that
we are now the old person going
i mean i do it all the time
when i was a kid they used to kick field
goals
and
you just have to have a sense of humor
about it i think that that's just just
something that happens to you
and um
i got to be honest with you but if
you're young and you listen to this
don't ever be afraid of getting old man
it's actually if you embrace it it's
[ __ ] awesome
it really is and and dressing your age
and all of that [ __ ] like i was talking
to my buddy and he went to something
recently
and he was saying
uh this is the one especially when you
become a parent this is one of the worst
things you could ever the most cringey
thing that you could do
is this guy was trying to be the cool
dad
you know the dad that despite the fact
that he had a kid he was still [ __ ]
cool right and and there was some guy he
was at some birthday party my buddy and
he said there was a dad there
that had his hat on sideways you know
like how rappers used to do it back in
the uh like flavor flavor some [ __ ] like
back in the 80s
like as a dad
like he's at a
he's had a [ __ ] kid's party
he's got his [ __ ] hat on sideways and
what's funny to me
is it's like
you know this isn't about you
can't you just let your kid be at the
party do you have to try and steal focus
like oh who's that who's that dad wow
he's still you know he's still with like
the popular kids
in the cafeteria
but then there's the other side like
maybe
maybe just you know
he grew up back then i don't know and
that's how you wore your hat and you
keep [ __ ] doing it i don't know
i'm i am a big [ __ ] believer though
that you gotta like uh
you know i'm not gonna go out there
dressed like [ __ ] wilford brimley on
stage but like
there is like a point i think you got to
put on a sport coat
i would do that to be honest with you
but i just
with my act i would just
i just feel like i would i would look
like uh
some [ __ ] trying to wear a sport coat
um so that's that's why i go with the
button down
i try to be with the button down uh
that's my happy medium you know what i
mean i'm not going to sit here and go up
and wear a [ __ ] suit on stage and act
like i'm a wordsmith
but i'm also not going to go up there
and whatever the latest [ __ ] thing
like i'm trying to think like the last
thing that i paid attention to
um
that people wear
somewhere around those vaughn dutch hats
i just stopped i was just like all right
i'm just [ __ ] old now i don't know
what this is i don't understand why
people who aren't truckers are wearing
trucker hats
oh here's a cool thing there's people
protesting across russia
and they're getting detained and all of
that
i would i wish i spoke russian to hear
what they're saying
you know
and what people are who aren't
protesting it and are supporting the
government are saying to the protesters
because over here if you protest war
they call you
they call you a communist and a
socialist so if you're in russia and
you're protesting that war do the people
that are for it go are you [ __ ]
capitalist
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know support the troops
um
i don't understand why all the people in
this country who are saying support the
troops are not supporting russian troops
invading a country like why don't why
don't you
just [ __ ] jump in all over the fence
support the troops unless they're other
people's troops
support what we're doing unless other
people are doing the exact same thing
just the [ __ ] irony of that is
hilarious to me
um but i refuse to watch any of that
[ __ ] coverage because i just can't
watch families getting uh
get a family died in front of my eyes
mayor and kiev suburb laments like all
of these stories exist
in all uh
all invasions i just don't understand
why people can't no
it's like sports fans when we do it
it's a good no call
when you do it it's cheating
um all right bill all right there
[ __ ] billy we are the world you've
made your [ __ ] point
um anybody from russia where you want to
write in i want to hear from you i want
to hear what you have to say
pro like what do you think do you think
your country's doing the right thing do
you think they're doing the wrong thing
what do you think about uh people in the
u.s going oh my god can you believe what
they're doing these people are terrible
terrible
um
that would be fascinating to me
to listen to and i'm going to say this
to both both americans and russians that
write in i understand that i don't know
what i'm talking about but it just seems
a little ridiculous
and uh meanwhile shout out to everybody
in the ukraine
[ __ ]
defending your country
i wish you didn't have to do it
um
all right plowing ahead let's get to
something a little lighter
i um
i watched this great youtube video
these two guys that like rebuild trucks
and they went through all the fords
all the gmc and all the dodges all the
different generations
of the trucks
and they rate them s
i don't know what s stands for that's
like sick or whatever the best level and
then it's just a through like f
and uh
speaking of dana carvey the redhead one
when on the dodge one when he wears the
glasses
looks like i think it's garth i never
really saw wayne's world to be honest
with you
um
he kind of looks like a redheaded
version of that but anyway they went
through all the fords
and they went through the chevys and i
realized why i'm not a chevy guy because
i don't think chevy has made a
good-looking truck since the square body
i'm just being honest um they were
talking about the cat eye one i could
see that that was all right
um i just haven't liked the chevy front
end but i love
you know from 1960 to like 1987
i love all of those chevys
um and i'm not one of those guys who's
just like if it's not ford folk dead you
know i like a lot of the dodge trucks
um
although their front end is a lot uglier
when you kind of look at it over the
years than i remember it being
but uh i i am i'm partial to the fords
and i realize that i like as far as
fords go i like the fifth generation
sixth seventh ninth
and fourteenth
and then the rest of them i don't know
like ford had a real bad period from
like 1997 the 10th 11th
and i would even say the 12th generation
were just like the front end just looked
terrible to me the 13th they got back on
track and then 14 they [ __ ] crushed
it
so if i ever did like an mtv cribs
i i i think i would i would have
all of those generation of trucks
and then um if i was gonna get a chevy i
would get
i like those ones like the late 70s
early 80s once
uh have to get a silverado
i know it's weird but i'm [ __ ] i'm
into trucks more so than i am into uh
to cars
but i'm never gonna do that [ __ ] though
i think you know
to be that person with like all of these
[ __ ] cars and [ __ ] like what do you
do with it speaking of which somebody
claimed the um
those those
uh climbing grips that i had
in my garage
if i'm gonna ship those out this week it
feels great that somebody took those i
got some other [ __ ] my garage if you
guys want to take this [ __ ] off my hands
um
i literally have one of those just one
of those gray shelves that it looks like
you'd put like uh
books on it whatever it has no back on
it you know those metal shelves
when i look at all the stuff i have on
there it's like i have not looked at or
used any of that other than the cooler
the cooler i take to the rose bowl every
year
my hockey stuff i have not [ __ ]
played since 2015 although i'm not
giving up on that
but i'm getting close of just getting
rid of this [ __ ] like it's taking up so
much [ __ ] room
um
just go back to being public skating guy
um
buckets of paint and [ __ ]
but i have a few more workout things i
might try to dump on you guys or i'll
just bring them to shows
just be like anybody here want a dustpan
which sounds so stupid but there's
always some pack rat in the [ __ ]
crowd that's gonna keep it
right oh dude i'd love one
you know have an extra [ __ ] dustpan i
mean that would be [ __ ] sick
this dustpan
i got the comic i got this this great
story with this dustpan
i was at a stand-up show swear to god
swear to god and the comic-con stage
comes out with the dustpan and he sets
it on the stool and you know i think
he's going to do a joke about it
you know i think there's got to be some
sort of you know we need to clean up
america or something i don't know he's
going to do next thing you know he just
goes you know who wants a dustband
and i'm telling you
there was 400 other people there in the
crowd and i somehow
got my hand up before they did you know
you know me you know me if i see an
opportunity i just go for
somebody's going to do that
uh uh by the way
shout out to coach k uh his final home
game
at the unbelievable camden indoor i feel
so lucky that i got to go to a duke
carolina game
when coach k was still coaching the team
um
i feel as happy about that as i feel
embarrassed that i lived in north
carolina from 1987 to 1988
and
jim valvano dean smith and coach k were
all coaching and i went to zero games
i could have saw all of those guys and i
didn't so at least i got to see coach k
um jim valvano and uh dean smith rest
their souls but anyway um it was great
to see all those duke players come back
and support him what a what a run what a
amazing coach and he coached for 42
years
at duke
and i remember thinking that going like
wow that's unbelievable this guy started
in 1980
and coached for 42 years and then i
started thinking wait a minute
i've been doing stand-up for 30 years
when i started stand-up
coach k
was only 12 years in
that's [ __ ] scary
um
that is scary life goes by
goes by quick there's nothing you can do
about it so you might as well try to
enjoy yourself there you go that's i
think that's today's lesson
all right bet mgm everybody oh my god
bet mgm okay we got march madness coming
up it's what it's all about bet mgm has
arrived in illinois
talk about betting in illinois
what is it different than betting in
indiana i don't know it's [ __ ] it's
awesome
you know you used to have to get on a
you're right in the middle of the
country like what are we gonna do we're
gonna fly a little longer and go to
vegas
or we're gonna go hang out with all
those skanks in atlantic city i don't
know
i don't know
[ __ ] it let's go to vegas i want to be
warm that's what they usually do
right
that's why when you go to atlantic city
you notice that it's it's really people
from like on the east coast
it really is east coast vegas you go to
vegas it's people from around all around
the country actually around the world
uh i would bet too like if you're coming
in from china
you know are you really going to fly
past vegas
or even europe you're going to fly all
the way to the united states you're
going to keep going right
anyway bet mgm has arrived and now you
don't have to do that now you can stay
in illinois you get better on dub bears
the cubs the white sox
you know
illinois university northwestern little
big ten action
uh you can bet on the blackhawks you get
bet on the bulls
what else they got there i don't know
illinois state i'm sure they got that
right
i bet there's an over under
speaking of illinois if they're going to
make another blues brother movie
if jolly jake from juliet illinois which
i think there's a prison there
it's going to come back um if you're in
illinois or any other state where bet
mgm is live live
sign up using bonus code burp b-u-r-r
and you'll get 200 free after placing
your first 10 bet regardless of the
outcome here's how it works download the
bet mgm app and sign up using bonus code
bur b-u-r-r take your first
10 bet on any event you'll receive 200
in free bets
um right after you place your first bet
stupid [ __ ] pad is back on
um you'll receive 200 in free bets right
after you place your first bet uh talk
about spring season sports march madness
nba or nhl notice we're not talking mlb
because they might be on strike nba and
the nhl playoffs
are uh it's all starting to heat up
people lebron just dropped 55 or 56 or
something jayson tatum dropped 54 points
are they on a collision course
because the nba knows that that'll be a
ratings bonanza bonanza but or is it
going to be the golden state warriors
versus the [ __ ] philadelphia 76ers
who knows march madness
talk about one of the greatest times
ever to have a bunch of action going on
the first night this what 32 [ __ ]
games
it's incredible i mean march is one of
the greatest gambling months
they'll ever be oh you also have st
patrick's day is he going to puke is he
not going to puke
uh how many times are they going to sing
the green alligators and the long neck
goose um will they actually have corned
beef sandwiches that sounds good right
now visit mgm.com for terms and
conditions 21 plus years of age or older
to wager arizona colorado dc iowa
illinois indiana louisiana maryland
michigan mississippi new jersey nevada
new york pennsylvania tennessee virginia
west virginia or wyoming only new
customer offer all promotions are
subject to qualification eligibility
requirements rewards issued as
non-withdrawal free bets foresight
credit free bets expire in seven days
from issues excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsible gaming problem 1 800 next
arizona 1-800-522-7000 for colorado dc
louisiana wyoming virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential health
michigan 1-800 gambler illinois indiana
maryland new jersey pennsylvania and
west virginia 1 800 bets off for iowa or
call 877 8 hope new york or text open
new york 467369 from new york or all
text tennessee redline 800 899
tennessee call 888 777-9696 mississippi
sports betting support georgia hawaii
ohio and utah and other states were
prohibited emotional offers not
available in nevada all right all look
who it is everybody
do me undies me undies
betting on basketball
me undies me undies you don't have to
wait till the fall
you can go in and see if you win
and if you don't and you [ __ ] your pants
my knees will be there to catch that
turd
with some of the softest [ __ ]
underwear
empty it out in the restroom sorry me
undies what's the first thing you you
put on every morning
if you answered my existential dread
then we have some friends who can help
with that but first what's the second
thing you put on every
every morning underwear right
let's let's assume when you sleep in the
nude me undies believes that when you
feel comfortable you can do anything yes
that includes having a positive outlook
on your day while wearing a fun and
ridic and ridiculous prince on your butt
uh what underwear do you always pick
from your drawer is it comfy cute can it
be both
i just at my age i just hope it fits
meundies makes the softest fabrics
you've ever put on your body so you can
sit on your couch all day or go out and
live your comfiest life once you try
their undies socks bralettes
and lounge thank god i got this acting
gig i was on my way to a bralette and
loungewear you'll never go back choose
from a range of limited edition prints
and colors in sizes from extra small to
4xl you can also sign up for their free
to join me undies membership where you
get a monthly subscription
um that sends new styles right to your
door plus enjoy discount pricing free
shipping and exclusive acts early access
to new launches myani's have great
offers for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 15 off and
free shipping
um me undies promise if you're not
satisfied with any product for any
reason you can return your order for a
full refund within 45 days to get 15
percent off your first order and free
shipping go to meundies.com
that's meundies m-e-u-n-d-i-e-s
dot-com
uh slash burr
me on dies.com
oh look who it is everybody it's bespoke
um you know from the makers of misspoke
comes bespoke bespoke post uh this
winner upgrade your daily routine with
bespoke post
and their new seasonal lineup of
must-have box of awesome collection
bespoke uh post partners
with small businesses and emerging
brands to bring you the most unique
goods every month i love the cigar
accessories no matter what you're into
box of awesome has you covered from
winter cocktails to cozy threads and
camping gear essentials box of awesome
has collections for every part of your
life survival kits gardner starters and
audio accessories to get started take
the quiz at box of awesome dot com your
answers will help them pick the right
box
the right box of awesome for you they
release new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories
i'm trying to like pronounce my r's and
actually say ohs like most of the
country
it's
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time each box is
valued at around seventy dollars
dollars as i say each box is valued
around seventy dollars but you only pay
a fraction of that price i feel like i'm
doing that guy in
on emphasis for family
um god is there for you plus with each
box of awesome you're supporting small
businesses 90 of everything that comes
in your box of awesome is from a small
up-and-coming brand get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome dot com and enter the
code burr at checkout that's box of
awesome dot com
code bur for twenty percent off your
first box box of awesome dot box of
awesome dot com code burr
how many more of these [ __ ] things so
i gotta read
two all right
oh look what it is everybody it's roman
there it is it's roman
when the moment for intimacy arrives you
need to be ready okay roman ready
all right when you whether you've been
in a relationship for years or just
getting started having the confidence
that comes from preparations means
you're free to enjoy the moment when the
moment comes even though you are far
from ordinary the truth is that erectile
dysfunction is really common in fact 52
of guys aged 40 to 70 experience some
form of erectile dysfunction go to get
roman.com burn now to uh speak to a u.s
licensed health care professional about
erectile dysfunction and get 15 off your
first month of treatment the benefits
from erectile dysfunction treatment can
help you reconnect with your partner and
rediscover the joy of sex hey remember
me look at my dick
[Music]
oh my god i'm so grateful we cannot
regroup roman's system is completely
confidential and totally discreet no big
logos or labels on packages with roman
you can get free online evaluation
ongoing care for
say with me erectile dysfunction all
from the comfort and privacy of your
home
take care of your ed without leaving
your home complete an online visit today
to connect with the us lice to connect
with a u.s licensed health care
professional and take care of it go to
getroman.com bird today and if you're
prescribed get 15 off your first month
of erectile dysfunction treatment make
sure you're ready to have confidence and
control this fall
roman ready
last one everybody it's all birds oh
this is all for the birds
all birds spring is so close you can
almost feel it it's so so it's the
perfect time to get outside and move
whether
whatever your speed do you think with
global warming they'll just stop talking
about spring and fall all birds just
released the new tree dasher
two
oh just released the new tree dasher 2
the next generation of their
best-selling insanely comfortable
running shoe made from a mix of natural
materials that's better for you and
better for the planet the tree dasher 2
is the next evolution of all birds
best-selling running shoe
adds comfort to run everything uh adds
comfort to everything run with lighter
more responsive foam extra grip and an
improved fit to keep you running
and nature winning made from all birds
the all birds roster of natural
materials like
merino wool
eucalyptus and sugar cane this everyday
running shoe softens impacts smooths
transition and continually delivers
comfort stride after stride
and they're also taking the time to give
a [ __ ] about the planet which is awesome
which i'm seeing is more and more with a
lot of these companies which is great
lighter more responsive foam adds
springs to every step
uh extra traction grips pavement
uh sugarcane-based sweet foam uh foam
midsoles made with the first carbon
negative evian resin eva resin
um it's it's look it's good for the uh
shoe laces are made from recycled
plastic bottles fantastic
spring forward with all birds tree
dasher 2 running shoe discover your
perfect pair at allbirds.com today
that's all birds a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot com for tree dasher two runnings for
the treetasher two running shoe
all right
i sort of glanced at some of the
some of the um
questions and [ __ ] i got i feel like i'm
gonna get trashed a lot here all right
go [ __ ] yourself dear bill bum
dear bill bum loving ginger [ __ ]
whether you are getting that pasty bald
no once looking body of you okay when
are you getting that pasty bald nonce
looking body of yours
over to the uk again what does nonce
mean i know that's not complimentary is
that some sort of elephant thing
n-o-n-c-e let's see what that is
nonce
coined
for or used
on one occasion
did i spell it right
wait a second what what the guys come on
you know i'm dumb
it says definition idiot all that in
fact i have to look it up i've never
heard that
how do you say it let's listen nuts
no it's okay
that's
no it's all right
what does it mean
not of normal
criminal element
oh it's a sex offender reference
jesus christ i'm sure you [ __ ]
[ __ ] in england enjoyed that whole
journey of me finding that out
[ __ ] soccer love and [ __ ]
all right
when are you getting that
pasty bald nonce-looking body of yours
over to
i have the body of a sex offender what
does that mean
um i don't want to hear excuses i want
to hear dates so i can book them if
you're big ginger [ __ ]
if you're a big ginger [ __ ] who's
scared to come here let your uk fans
know
so we can spend our money on someone
funnier than you all the best and go
[ __ ] yourself what are you being afraid
to go there i went and i shot a special
there
are you talking about the covid [ __ ]
um you know when they open it up i'll go
over there
listen i'm sorry your dad rejected you
that you're already assuming that i'm
not going to come back over there
to that land of [ __ ] food
oh my god
please if i ever go to liverpool again
the only one of my contractors you have
to tell me that there's a good place to
eat there oh my god i struck out
like four times when i was there and it
was every one of them was worse than the
next
um
all right ginger baker versus john
bonham
this [ __ ] guy just slaps me around
listen to this
i was so excited to hear people maybe
break down ginger baker's style nobody
gives a [ __ ] and this guy just writes
bill i'm 42 years old and i'm tired of
asking who's better when it comes to
dumb [ __ ] like this they were both good
at what they did and who they did it for
it's as dumb as arguing over who was the
better teenage mutant ninja turtle i'm
not mad that you're talking about but
more so think you're trying to be a nice
guy and consider something you hadn't
in this debate what
but but more so think you're trying to
be a nice guy and consider something you
hadn't in this debate
so it's settled both are great
and bakers is a bit boring are we good
good
um i was with you till that last
bit where you just decided it was over
so it's settled
both are great baker is a bit are we
good
and then he goes good the answer's for
me ah jesus christ
i can tell you this right now i am so
glad i'm not [ __ ] riding in a car
with you
hey you want to talk about this look you
have your opinion i have my opinion are
we good good settled
[Music]
you want to listen to the radio no
that'll just create more arguments we
fine fine
all right
um
all right two of the bank robbery
stories are [ __ ]
dear billy bald bandit congratulations
on the acting gig i know you're going to
kill it thank you i can only imagine
acting takes a lot of hard work but you
always come across as very natural on
screen all right i actually wrote this
for everybody
i did
um
speaking of people pretending that
things happened to them i'm calling
[ __ ] on two of the bank robbery
stories
were read on the podcast
oh god there always has to be that
person that just has to ruin your good
time to tell you that santa claus
doesn't exist i don't care they were
funny stories
all right
the first story i'm calling out is the
calgary knife dealer tail
you don't think a knife dealer on the
streets of calgary isn't carrying a
bigger sharper knife for personal
protection
um i'll be honest with you i didn't
understand that story is if it was i
thought it was like a dope fiend that
stole some [ __ ] and was trying to sell
it and one of them was a knife
[Music]
all um so you're just calling
i like how you said you said two of the
bank robbery stories are [ __ ]
and now you have no evidence you're just
saying that they're you're speculating
that they're [ __ ] all right
the second story i'm calling out is the
one about the cheerleader working at a
craft story in florida the story teller
bringing up the point that they looked
the part of a cheerleader was
unnecessary
that's how you know a woman is telling a
story when it's
it's always about what
they looked like yeah that's what that
actually gave it authenticity
so he's a cheerleader you know i looked
apart i was quite a
i was the looker back in the day you
know that's like a guy talking about you
know all the touchdowns
that he scored in that game and you just
can't find any evidence of it so you
have to believe
okay i guess you were a football hero 20
years ago anyway uh you're going to tell
me that a high school cheerleader is
going to have the response time and
articulation to say her long-winded
reply to to the bank robber about she
how she has to convince herself not to
steal all the money out of the cash
register every day
if i were the robber i'd be sitting
there like wait
you have to say that to yourself but you
have to say to
you have to say to yourself that every
day
you wouldn't
empty the shut just shut the [ __ ] up and
start putting the money in the bag
oh you're saying that that was too long
i don't get what you're saying here
beautiful people can't be all so smart
or beautiful people can be smart but
they're too long-winded i know guys you
know
let's why don't we just all just take
the [ __ ] ride
you get through your commute or your
flight and enjoy the [ __ ] podcast we
don't have to debunk this [ __ ] like
we're [ __ ]
i don't know anyway i have been loving
this segment
of bank robbery stories but i'd hate for
it to turn into the stream steaming pile
of [ __ ]
that you read on ask
reddit threads thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself
um
thanks
i don't know what any of that was but
evidently this guy he knows everything
that's real and everything that isn't
um
all right jesus christ why don't you get
in the car with that [ __ ] bottom uh
ginger baker [ __ ]
all right robbery story bronx new york
2002. all right i'm calling
[ __ ] on the other guy above me
saying that this was [ __ ] before i
even read it all right hey bill huge fan
back in 2001 2002 i was working for a
real shady stereo company they used to
put a bunch of stereos in a trunk truck
for us and we would drive around
pretending that the items were hot when
they weren't
oh that's amazing
the idea behind this was that it would
get customers all excited to be buying
something hot and getting a crazy deal
when they really weren't i did that with
stereo speakers way back in the 80s
these stereos would be valued at 100 to
200
and we would tell them they were worth
thousands
um
so they didn't have any issue paying
five to six hundred for a system that
they thought was worth two thousand and
stolen
i only lasted a few weeks on that
horrific job well that's what you get
for buying stolen property one day we
were in manhattan and this guy
and his little partner comes up to us
and tells us he will buy our entire
truck at cost and give us a thousand
dollars each on top of it
and he seemed to know exactly what we
were doing
is this a cop
no he couldn't do that because that
would be entrapment uh me and two idiots
the two idiots i was with got together
and we all had a bad feeling about it
but decided to go along with it in case
we can each make 100 grand it would be
worth it oh no he told us to follow him
to his house in the bronx and drop it
off there
oh boy that's when i said no way but
they insisted and overruled me we got to
this apartment dropped off the equipment
and as we were putting down the last few
pieces
he stood by one of the stereos held the
gun out and said thanks now get the [ __ ]
out of here
wow he did not have to finish the
sentence for me to already be in the
truck
i was not dying for this garbage job
wow that's amazing
or complete [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
well
you know that's you play the game that's
how it goes all right dumb shoplifter
hey there oh billy red white and blue
balls
uh
oh my god
do you realize how great that is red
white and blue balls i got red pubes
i'm a white guy
you know i'm married red white and blue
balls that's [ __ ] amazing that is
[ __ ] amazing congratulations
i used to and i'm an american
right proud to be an american
i don't know what that means i think it
means do whatever i want to do
as long as i'm white
um i used to be an underground
undercover security agent at a big
retail store not bragging
my main job was walking around acting
like i was shopping and watching for
shoplifters and then catching them as
they left the store one time this
dumbass stole some socks and a pack of
wife-beater tank tops so my partner and
i busted him and brought him back to our
office in handcuffs
while he was sitting there he was
fidgeting around a lot with his back
pocket so i told him to take out
whatever it was he was messing around
with
he dropped
he dropped a crack pipe on the floor
i went to put it in a plastic bag for
the cops but when he saw me do this he
decided to smash it into our carpet
floor
the dumb [ __ ] didn't realize that
shoplifting and possession of a pipe
were only misdemeanors but tampering
with evidence bumps it up to a felony
not to mention it pissed us off because
we were going to have to clean nasty
crack pipe debris out of our carpet
anyways
i have a bunch of stories like this
about idiots stealing from stores so
i might email you again sometimes yeah
that's like those onion fields the onion
field murders
when that guy said to the cop uh
are you familiar with the lindbergh law
and he said yes and then he shot the cop
and he didn't realize that
kidnapping didn't
what was it you didn't get the death
penalty the lindbergh law unless you
crossed state lines
so he didn't have to kill the guy
well i mean i don't know what he had to
do i wouldn't have done it that's what
i'm saying all right shut up bill okay
opposite of how do i tell my wife she's
fat
all right
guys right in their wife
their wives are getting fat and they
want to tell them
you know because they don't want them to
you know have poor quality life die soon
and they also don't want to be you know
[ __ ] a bean bag
just being honest here uh dear uncle
baby billy
uh when listening to the podcast for
probably 10 years been listening
broadcast for probably 10 years now the
first time i heard the podcast i was
hook you did this hilarious thing where
you pretended to read the news but you
did it in the voice and tone of a
catholic priest
singing during mass
as a catholic it was the funniest thing
i ever heard oh i didn't know i used to
do that i didn't remember doing that
let me see let's bring that back for a
bit
i already look up nonce
i still forget what that
uh
means
the sexual creep guy
all right let's
let's see if we do it if this still
works here
don't allow
don't allow don't [ __ ] miss
officials identify six killed in madison
county
tornado outbreak you'll never see them
again
why did you go outside
didn't you watch the movie twister
at least now you're dead you won't be
buying plastic i don't know if that
works anymore um i need advice for some
on something i haven't heard
on your podcast before it's my wife
she's 37
beautiful and a great mom and a great
wife but she has several unhealthy
habits she smokes cigarettes she eats
fast food daily
and all
she drinks is pepsi she also eats candy
like a child yeah she's not going to
make 60.
can't do that here's the the issue
whenever i bring up her unhealthy habits
she lifts her skirt to show me her flat
stomach and says
worry about yourself because i look good
oh my god i love this woman
it's true she does look good i don't
know how she manages to keep her
metabolism so high at age 37 because she
never works out
she just eats junk food and somehow
stays thin
maybe she [ __ ] chews and spits i
don't know i on the other hand
i'm a lot like you i'm in decent shape
for my age but i have to actively
monitor what foods i eat and how much
booze i drink and make sure i stay
active in order to not be a fatty i'm
worried about her health long term and
feel like at some point all of these
unhealthy habits are going to catch up
to her
and the beautiful woman i love will be
obese with rotten teeth and diabetes i
mean that's a pretty good forecast
how do i get her to start eliminating
some of these bad habits now before it's
too late
thanks and i'll see you in hanover
maryland in august this august um i
don't know that you can't
i mean what are you gonna tie her down
and [ __ ] force her to eat vegetables
you can't
i'll just say this i i would just say
you know you got a flat stomach now but
one of these days that's all going to
catch up with you
you know
the outside looks good i would not want
to see your insides and there's plenty
of [ __ ] skinny people that just drop
dead
um
eating like that they just don't show i
mean i don't know i don't get to some of
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's happened to some
of my friends but you know i i know a
few guys that were in shape
and just you know
i don't know all right let's leave that
alone all right
overrated
underrated
underrated not having neighbors
i just moved out of the city and now i
don't have to worry about
[ __ ] all when it comes to the smoke from
my grill or the loud man yelling
[ __ ] [ __ ] on my podcast i'm
listening to that is so amazing you know
i really think about like living in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere you don't have
to soundproof a room you could just play
drums you could play drums in your yard
would be [ __ ] incredible
unless you have your headphones on and
some bear was sneaking up behind you
then that would suck all right overrated
religious
non-religious people you know the type
hard-lined atheist or someone who
trashes religion or the catholic church
rightfully so sometimes wait are you
talking about me they can't imagine
their hero politician doing anything
wrong
so they make up dumb excuses for them
like the people who make up excuses for
their dumb religion wait religious
non-religious people let me read this
again you know the type hard-line
atheists on someone who trashes religion
catholic church oh oh oh
oh hard line atheist or
someone who trashes religion or catholic
church rightfully so you're talking
about
someone who doesn't believe in the [ __ ]
that can't imagine
hear a politician doing anything wrong
okay you're just talking about yeah
non-receptive [ __ ] which is something
i am sometimes
um
anyway
that is the podcast everybody um
thanks for hanging in there i know i
have limited [ __ ] to talk about because
i'm [ __ ]
you know i get to do this amazing
project but it really it's just freaking
12-hour days
i come home i go to sleep and anytime
that i'm awake i just hang with my kids
so
just hang with me over the next four or
five weeks i'll get through this shoot
and i will be back to
talking about all the dumb [ __ ] that's
going on out there all right
that is it
go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll check in on
you on thursday
you